on sent effectivement au delà d'un
laxisme d'ailleurs un décrochage total
de l'autorité de l'état sur toute la
chaîne qui composent la sécurité depuis
les questions de prévention
je rappelle que depuis qu emmanuel
macron est élu il n'y a toujours pas de
stratégie de la prévention de la
délinquance dans notre pays qu'il a
d'ailleurs plus de directeur depuis
quelques quelques jours ça fait trois
ans que nous attendons donc les communes
font avec leurs moyens mais sans
véritable soutien de l'état la question
de la répression ou les effectifs de
police ne sont pas au rendez-vous mais
sur la question de la de la justice
parce qu'il faut que la chaîne a eu lieu
jusqu'au bout là aussi on voit quand
même des lacunes qui coûte extrêmement
cher à la tranquillité et à la sécurité
de notre pays
quand madame belloubet décide d'annuler
les peines de prison inférieures à six
mois eh ben c'est finalement un signal
envoyé à toutes les délinquances
qu'elles ne risquent rien et pourquoi
et bien parce qu'elle annule le plan
prisons avec les 15000 places qui devait
être créé pour toute la chaîne qui
composent la sécurité publique on voit
que le gouvernement est totalement
absent et on voit un président de la
république
on l'a vu malheureusement avec des
scènes terrifiantes pendant la crise des
gilets jaunes on voit la police mais
complètement dépassé par les événements
dans toutes les villes
le présent la république se drape de
mots mais pendant la crise et gilet
jaune on en a aussi beaucoup entendu et
moi je vois pas la situation évolue et
tolérance zéro c'est très bien qu'il
donne les moyens à la police à la
justice à la prévention délinquance aux
collectivités de l'état ne veut pas
faire et bien qu'ils donnent les moyens
à ceux qui sont au plus près des
difficultés notamment sur les questions
de la maison de castex peut-être que
j'encadre xv à vous écouter le bruit là
encore espoir par les mots en parlant de
proximité nous attend de voir comment ça
va se traduire dans les faits j'ai
disposé en dehors de chez eux jean
castex qui veut s'appuyer sur les
territoires il faut véritablement donner
les moyens aux collectivités de faire et
pas simplement comme on en a eu trop
l'habitude depuis trois ans se
débarrasser des problèmes que l'état ne
sait pas gérer sur les mers sans leur en
donner les moyens